thor ragnarok was directed by Taika
Waititi the man behind hunt for the
wildered in the shadows two films I
loved so I was pretty excited to see
what he could do with a Marvel movie and
this time around Thor is imprisoned
forced to fight Hulk in a gladiator
battle while hella the goddess of death
threatens to destroy all of Asgard and
please stay tuned to the end of this
video because I'm doing something very
special with the fine folks at Full Sail
University and a lot of my viewers are
interested in getting a film degree I'm
gonna be having a discussion about that
at the end of this video when it comes
to Thor Ragnarok this film does for Thor
what Captain America the Winter Soldier
did for cap because before Winter
Soldier cap was cool and he was you know
he's cool Captain America but that movie
was like oh my god
Captain America is just incredible this
film is exactly what Thor needed he
needed a major boost of fun and
likability and a great sense of
freshness what's so great about Ragnarok
is that it takes everything we know
everything that's been established about
Thor and it dismantles it his hammer
forget about it it's gone his macho
sense of right and wrong played for
comedy but it also keeps the heart of
his character intact the family dynamics
the struggle with his brother and his
father and now a new thing that he has
to deal with in hella played excellently
by Kate Blanchet by the way everyone in
this movie steals the movie there was
not one specific character that stole
the film for me because everyone was
doing such a great job that they all
stole the movie Tessa Thompson Jeff
Goldblum Mark Ruffalo Chris Hemsworth
even Taika Waititi as Korg they're all
fantastic this is one of my favorite
Marvel movies this is everything I want
to see in a superhero movie it's
extremely fun and likable when the
action scenes are there they're like
adrenalin fuel they're extremely badass
and beautifully shot this is a very
colorful movie which is something I was
happy to see because the other Thor
movies I'm fine with them they're
enjoyable you can watch them but they
were easily some of the weakest of all
the MCU films this is without a doubt
easily the best of the Thor franchise
and one of my favorite
Marvel movies one of the biggest issues
that I had with the MC use treatment of
Thor was that it seemed I can't confirm
this but it seemed like the creator's
didn't think audiences would appreciate
such an obscure character unless they
brought him quite literally down to
earth and put him in earth and gave him
human friends on earth like Jane and
Darcy these are not the things I want to
see in a Thor movie and you don't have
to have a strange godlike character
around us in New York to be the likable
for us this movie understands that and
it's an adventure movie he goes all over
the place and fights different beings of
all different kinds but you care because
he feels like a person and it's because
of great writing and great acting
according to Taika Waititi he has said
that 80% of this movie was improvised
that's astounding because so much of it
feels very well created and controlled
in regards to the humor it's so well
timed and some might have an issue with
this this is an extremely funny movie
and quite often rather than having a
very serious moment it will be played
for a joke and that's one of the best
things about this film I believe this is
the 17th MCU movie at some point this
series is going to have to acknowledge
and be very self-aware of itself and
make fun of itself and Ragnarok does
that something else I loved was that
they actually have the immigrant song in
the movie it wasn't just for the trailer
so often you hear songs and trailers and
you begin to attach that with your
anticipation for the movie and then it's
nowhere to be heard in the movie I was
so glad they actually had it
incorporated in some really badass
moments in the film there were moments
of action here then where I got chills
like it gave me goosebumps it was so
exciting you actually get to see Thor
being the god of thunder not just
calling down some lightning bolts with
his hammer they get rid of so many of
the things that we're used to seeing in
a Thor movie that it became very
surprising consistently because you go
to a Thor film at this point expecting
to see certain things you go to an MCU
movie at this point expecting to see
certain things
this film constantly sidestepped those
expectations that we go into these types
of movies with to create a really fresh
experience and
that is due to excellent writing and
great directing and I have to give it
the Taika Waititi because in fairly 80%
of this movie was improvised that's a
lot of him going back and forth with the
actors creating something that's really
cool
it's just so rare that I find movies
where I'm consistently smiling I'm
wrapped up in the movie and I'm
forgetting that I'm watching one because
it's just so investing and just such a
damn good time these movies aren't made
as much as you would think often times
you see a movie like yeah that was kind
of fun but it was just diverting this is
a movie that is so enjoyable to
experience that I just forgot I was
watching one after a while and I was
excited to see what would happen next
and that's one of the beauties of seeing
a great film when you realize that you
just wrapped up in it and it's so rare
it's so rare when you really think about
it that that happens and and ragnark
did that for me I'm a huge Planet Hulk
fan it's easily my favorite of any of
the Hulk comics so I was really happy to
see a lot of that incorporated into this
movie quite more of it than I expected
which really brought a smile to my face
so if you are a fan of Planet Hulk like
me you're gonna have a blast with a lot
here Jeff Goldblum as the Grand Master
is everything I wanted I don't care that
he's basically being like the
personification of our thoughts of who
Jeff Goldblum is that's fine with me
I'll watch him go uh-huh yes like any
day all the time I don't care it's
perfect as for issues with the movie yes
there are a lot of jokes and sometimes
there may have been just a few too many
and it's not because there's too many
jokes it's more about where to put them
and how to incorporate more serious
scenes with the levity honestly 90% of
time it's flawless there were just a few
times where I had laughed so much that
the humor came so much more and I was
like okay I just laughed
I need give me a second to to process
and that's really it's just like a minor
thing you know it's something you don't
really care about it doesn't really
affect for me anyway the experience of
this movie but I'm mentioning it because
I thought of it also hella well great I
thought Blanchette was phenomenal
sometimes her character can be a real
exposition
Pease she will show art on the ceiling
explaining her backstory she'll be
talking a lot to Carl Urban's character
saying you don't notice about me but
this is kind of like what happened but
she's really telling the audience
because her character comes with so much
backstory and they really have to
address a lot of it but again honestly
this isn't really anything that bothered
me it's just something that I feel like
some people may notice from a
screenwriting perspective these flaws
are so minimal that I just I had a blast
this is a really fun movie it's a great
superhero movie easily the best Thor
movie I'm gonna give thor ragnarok and a
definitely check this one out guys if
you're a fan of the MCU I found it
extremely exciting and fun and fresh and
all the things I wanted ever Thor movie
but like I said I am doing something
pretty cool with Full Sail University
Full Sail University is the ultimate
education destination for those film
industry enthusiasts Full Sail offers
students the opportunity to take their
film experience to the next level with
programs and film or online digital
cinematography these courses provide
students with the chance to work on a
film from start to finish learning about
each member's role in production
filmmaking students can learn about
artistic concepts and technical tools
for every angle including documentary
commercial production and web video
working in the film industry is an
exciting and rewarding experience if you
know you want to be a part of it but
don't know where to begin this is a good
place to start full sail grads have
worked on films and TV shows like Doctor
Strange Star Trek beyond Captain America
Civil War and The Walking Dead I know a
lot of my viewers are very interested in
obtaining a film degree or a career in
film this is something that also myself
is extremely important and I hope that a
lot of you do check out Full Sail dot
edu slash Chris Stockman to learn more
about a degree at Full Sail University
and thank you very much to them for
sponsoring this video and thank you to
you guys for watching it means the world
to me you're the best and as always if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]